[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كثره الربيع يجلب الذباب فالذباب يتواجد
مع الربيع والغراب يتواجد مع الجد وهل
الاولين الله يرحمهم يقولون اللهم اجعلها
سنه ذباب ولا تجعلها سنه جراد والناموس
اللغه والبعوض يتواجد في حال اعتدال
الاجواء وحول المياه الاثنه كمستنقعات
الامطار وغيرها وذكر البعوض قال له هو
الناموس يتغذى على المياه وعلى رحيق
النباتات والانثى هي التي تلسع وتنقل
الامراض وتتغذى على الدماء لانها هامه في
نقدي بيوضها والحشرات وجميع الهوام السامه
العقارب والثعابين تتواجد في اول ايام
الصيف كحال ايامنا هذه خاصه في الارض
المشار ابعد عن الداب
واشترته
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
والمولى سبحانه خلق هذا الكون بتناغم
وتوازن وبنسب متناسقه ان كل شيء خلقناه
بقدر وكثره الحشرات خلال هذا الوقت يتزامن
مع هجره الطيور ليش لان الطيور المهاجره
تتغذى على هذه الحشرات ولذلك اهلنا ولينا
الله يرحمهم كانوا يحرثون الارض خلال هذا
الوقت حتى تتغذى عليها الطيور شكوت الى
سرب الخطا اذ مررنا به فقلت ومثلي بالبكاء
جدير اسر بالقطع هل من معير جناحه لعلي
الى من قد هويته اطير
[موسيقى]